the challenges
facing our world are growing all the
time
how do we build stronger economies with
equal opportunities for all
how do we build a sustainable world for
generations to come
how do we protect our cities and harness
the power of technology
for our common benefit
humanity has always been good at forward
thinking
in this series using the latest
bloomberg research and analysis
we will make sense of the problems of
tomorrow
inequality sustainability
urbanization the gender gap and the
demographic time bomb
and in this film the march of the
machines
what effect will artificial intelligence
have on the world of work
will a machine soon be doing your job
does the rise of the robot
mean the full of humanity
[Music]
the world is changing today we stand on
the brink of a fourth
industrial revolution one that will
transform the way we work
the way we live and even what makes us
human
there's a group of technologies that are
combining
to create transformation across almost
every industry at the moment
and those technologies include things
like artificial intelligence
3d printing robotics
big data and then some things in on the
sort of life sciences front in terms of
genetics and
and medical imaging and that these
things are sort of combining in a way
that's bringing about a host of
transformative changes
across industries
i would describe the fourth industrial
revolution
actually quite similarly to how i would
describe the past three
and that is technology that leads
to massive gains and productivity and
massive gains in productivity
mean substantial improvements to
everyone's quality of
life
the world has been through revolutions
before
the advent of mechanization then
electronics then the digital revolution
all profoundly changed the world's
economies
[Music]
but this revolution could be even more
disruptive
i think in previous revolutions you
could really talk about them as
industrial revolutions what was changing
was how things were made
factories industry often heavy industry
in particular
here you're seeing transformation across
really a whole range of not just
industry but services and and the
creation of whole new
business models that didn't exist before
what's different a little bit about
this particular revolution is that um
it gets into a whole range of things
that people only thought were ever only
possible
for humans to do jobs that work human
jobs before
aren't going to be human jobs anymore at
the heart of this fourth revolution
is artificial intelligence the ability
of machines to match
and perhaps one day surpass the
cognitive ability of their human
creators
what's happening now is a big deal it is
making a big difference in the way
people live
the way people interact with each other
it is sort of obliterating distance
it is in some cases removing humans from
tasks that we once thought were
the sole province of the human mind
these analytic tasks
that we thought only a human brain could
do we're suddenly finding that
algorithms can do that machines can do
these are early days in the brave new
world of artificial intelligence
but the potential benefits are vast
what are some of the liberating benefits
of artificial intelligence they're
actually a lot
if you think about something just like
driverless cars autonomous vehicles
which is one use of ai that people are
talking about
that could have a really liberating
impact on a lot of people's lives if you
think about older people
who can no longer drive they're very
shut in their houses right now very
dependent on others for transportation
with driverless cars they would be able
to go about their daily life and then
you're seeing with big data
that this may have a profound impact on
drug development that you'll find
new pharmaceuticals being developed at a
faster rate to cure diseases
because the computer is essentially able
to sort through the data
and pick up connections that otherwise
would be missed
for health in particular the advantages
of machine learning data science are
immense
those have an incredible chance to
address very both very
infrequent diseases and diseases which
affect different parts of the population
very differently
if we're going to cure cancer it's
probably going to come through data
science
but there is potentially a darker side
to this technological revolution
one which could profoundly change the
world of work as we know it
[Music]
a technological revolution will cost
jobs
it'll cost jobs in the areas that see
the biggest advancements first
a good example of that that is feasible
over the near term
is truck driving you have self-driving
trucks
you don't need the 3.5 million truck
drivers that you have right now in the
u.s
what is key as part of this revolution
as productivity goes up as the economy
continues to evolve
and new jobs are created you need to
make sure those displaced workers
are given the skills to move into these
new positions
that's what's key will all of them be no
but
i think the key point is you need to
make sure if you've lost 3.5 million
jobs in one sector
how do you create more than that in
another sector and i think
in past industrial revolutions that's
what we've seen happen
and hopefully and i think it will it
will be what happens again
but what if this doesn't happen
[Music]
martin ford is a software entrepreneur
he has peered into our future economy
and sees a world where potentially
hundreds of millions of skilled workers
are out of a job i would say that if you
look
far enough into the future there is no
job anywhere in our economy there's
nothing that anyone does that is
completely safe and that includes even
artists and
novelists and you know the kinds of jobs
that you would imagine right now are
completely
beyond the scope of artificial
intelligence millions and millions of
those jobs are going to be lost
and it's unlikely that enough jobs are
going to be created to absorb all of
those workers
[Music]
martin ford is a software entrepreneur
who has a chilling vision of the future
his best-selling books have put him at
the forefront of a movement which
worries about technology
the speed of its growth and the immense
potential it has to change the world
this is the fourth industrial revolution
the advent of machines
powered by artificial intelligence which
have the potential to make redundant
hundreds of millions of workers across
the planet
it is a world which is nearly upon us
but which governments and businesses
are only starting to comprehend
well the central idea in my latest book
the rise of the robots is that over time
machines computers smart algorithms are
increasingly going to substitute for
human labor i think that that's
inevitable
technology is eventually going to be
able to
do many of the things that people now do
and i think there's a good chance that
that will result in unemployment it's
going to push people out of the labor
force many people are going to
find it impossible to adapt to that
because they're not going to have
capabilities that really exceed what
machines can do and that's i think going
to be a genuine concern both for our
society of course
and ultimately for the economy too
some of those machines are already with
us
[Music]
there are already algorithms that can
interpret things like body language and
respond to some extent to emotion that
can determine your mood for example and
so forth and
you know this has big implications
imagine what that could mean for example
for advertising if an algorithm can
determine
exactly how you're feeling and then
target advertisements at you based on
that
some of the language trans translation
things that have been demonstrated are
truly remarkable imagine if anyone in
any country who speaks any language
would now be able to do any job because
we have perfect
machine translation in real time between
languages so
you know that has real implications for
the job market obviously
we may already be starting to see the
effect on the wider economy
in the first decade of this century the
net total number of jobs created in the
united states
was zero what we see
is that in the united states we've been
having
what we call jobless recovery so clearly
there's something happening there and i
think part of what's happening
is that jobs disappear when a recession
happens and then when
finally recovery comes back companies
find that they're able to leverage
technology
to avoid higher rehiring a lot of those
workers
and so it's taking longer and longer for
the jobs to reappear
throughout history technology has always
disrupted economies and societies
in the late 19th century 50 percent of
u.s workers were employed on farms
by 2000 it was less than two percent
those workers found work in other
sectors
but martin thinks this time it's
different
what transformed agriculture was a
specific mechanical technology
now we've got a technology that's really
just ubiquitous it's across the board
artificial intelligence is something
that's just scaling across our entire
economy it's not something
that's impacting just one sector it's
something that literally is everywhere
and as a result it means that there
isn't really going to be any safe haven
for workers
what makes the new technology so
ubiquitous is the development of a new
virtual world
the world of big data well big data
essentially
is the collection and use of just
massive amounts of data
in big corporations for example these
companies are collecting all kinds of
information
about their customers about their
business operations about
the actual processes in in industrial
environments and factories about the
things that their employees are doing
all of this data essentially becomes a
kind of feedstock for these smart
algorithms it
it becomes the information that they use
to learn
and and basically to figure out how to
do things and that's something that is
just going to be
i think dramatically disruptive going
forward
the total data stored on the world's
computers is now believed to be well
over 1 000
billion gigabytes and it is big data
which is driving the most disruptive
advance in technology
the ability of machines to think
one thing that you'll very often hear
people say even today is that computers
only do what their programs
do and you know this is really not right
anymore and and the reason it's not
right is basically because of machine
learning because we now have this
technology
that allows smart software algorithms to
look at data
and based on that to to learn to learn
how to do things to figure things out
to make predictions so it really is no
longer the case that some human being is
sitting
down and telling a computer exactly what
to do step by step
computers are now having the ability to
figure that out for themselves
you can imagine a future where every
device every appliance
all kinds of industrial equipment
everything communicates and talks to
each other and i think that one of the
things will happen is that
artificial intelligence will kind of use
that as a platform it will scale across
all of that everything will become more
intelligent
the last great technological advance saw
robots replace
millions of blue collar jobs in
factories and on production lines
martin believes this new disruption is
going to target the white collar
workforce as well
once a a computer learns to do something
then that
that information can be scalable out to
any number of machines so it's almost as
like
you can imagine having a workforce of
people and you could train one employee
to do a particular task
and then you could clone that worker and
and have a whole
army of those workers that's a bit like
the way artificial intelligence works so
machine learning is is very scalable if
you've got the kind of job where
someone else another smart person should
maybe watch what you're doing or
study everything you've done in the past
and figure out how to do your job then
it's a pretty
good bet that eventually there'll be an
algorithm that will come along and be
able to do
you know essentially that that same
approach so
that's a lot of jobs
many of the jobs which might be
displaced are those currently occupied
by educated
highly paid workers
so you can see really across the board
that anyone sitting in front of a
computer
doing some sort of routine predictable
knowledge work for example if they're
cranking out the same report or the same
analysis again and again
all of that is going to be very
susceptible to this journalism is one
interesting area that's being impacted
by this because there are now systems
that
can essentially tap into data and then
they can transform that data into a very
compelling news story that many people
would read and they can't tell that it
was written by a machine
in the future maybe 90 percent of new
stories will be machine
generated
the number of jobs displaced has the
potential to utterly transform the
economic landscape
there have been a couple of studies done
most notably by a couple of researchers
at oxford university and they looked at
a number of countries and most of the
results have come back
suggesting that up to half of the jobs
could be susceptible
to automation perhaps over the next 20
years
that's 60 million jobs in the united
states alone
that's a staggering number obviously we
have a massive social problem you'd have
tremendous stress on government in terms
of trying to take care of all these
people that no longer have an income
i think that you would see the potential
for a massive
economic downturn because you would run
out of consumers you no longer have
people that are capable
of buying the products and services that
are being
produced by the economy
a revolution on this scale wouldn't just
transform an economy
it would have immense implications for
our society
we could really have just what you might
call inequality on steroids
the very wealthy people who own all this
technology are going to do
extraordinarily well
you would have the potential for civil
unrest perhaps even
riots or massive crime waves
in the united states during the great
depression we had an unemployment rate
of about 25
and back then there were many people
genuinely concerned that that would
result in the collapse of
both democracy and capitalism
this situation amounts to just about the
end of the world as we know it
a science fiction nightmare straight
from the movies
there are some very prominent thinkers
like for example stephen hawking and
elon musk who have
raised genuine fears about the potential
for advanced artificial intelligence and
their concern is that someday we're
going to build a super intelligent
machine
imagine a machine that's a hundred or
maybe a thousand times smarter than any
living person uh what would that system
think how would it act would it have a
use for us
uh it might decide that we're simply a
burden it might
decide to just get rid of us so it could
potentially present an existential
threat
is that something to worry about i think
that it's not a silly concern it's not
something that we should laugh at and
just dismiss
[Music]
there's really no endpoint to this
there's no point at which you can say
this is absolutely as far as we can go
and machines will never
go beyond this we are reaching a new era
a time when things are going to operate
differently and we need to adapt to that
healthcare is one area of the economy
already adapting to this disruption
and in this field researchers hope that
intelligent humans
and intelligent machines can work
together for everyone's benefit
[Music]
the fourth industrial revolution the era
of artificial intelligence
has arrived computers are now mastering
tasks once considered the sole preserve
of humans
and putting millions of jobs at risk
and now business leaders are wrestling
with the potentially huge implications
in general robots of one form or another
are going to become much more
omnipresent in our lives
in a good way they'll replace a lot of
repetitive activities that people are
currently doing
robots will have a dramatic effect on
the labor pool
lower the cost of products people will
start to realize that just about every
manual task eventually will probably be
done by a robot
martin ford's books have highlighted the
threat to the job market
but even he sees areas where artificial
intelligence could be beneficial
i do think that healthcare is actually
one of the areas where
the impact of artificial intelligence
and robotics could be extraordinarily
positive in the future
the burden on our economy is growing at
a remarkable rate especially in the
united states
so if we can deploy more artificial
intelligence and robotics there to make
that more efficient that'll be a great
thing
analysts expect the ai healthcare market
to generate revenues of over
6 billion by 2021 10 times its current
total
young companies like hindsight in new
jersey and analytic in california
are mining data to improve patient
outcomes across a range of illnesses
and in new york ibm researchers have
developed watson
an intelligent software system at the
forefront of this revolution
it can understand somebody's personality
type it can
look at email for example and tell you
what is the tone of the email
uh you know what kind of messages are
coming through whether you internet them
or not right
it can look at for example a big
encyclopedia
extract all the concepts and the
relationship among those concepts
[Music]
watson operates in the world of big data
extracting knowledge from the billions
of facts and figures floating through
cyberspace
i look at the world from the point of
view of
you know the amount of data that there
is um and the amount of
knowledge that is embedded or insights
that's embedded in the data that we're
not able to extract today
and therefore we are not able to make
the right decisions
so um the fourth industrial revolution
to me
is the ability to have a much
better understanding of the world
through all of the data
and therefore making better decisions
for it
[Music]
ibm is currently running a research
project in which watson augments the
intelligence of medical professionals
helping doctors treat the most dangerous
diseases in the world
including skin cancer
[Music]
melanoma is a very deadly form of skin
cancer
and it's something where early detection
and intervention
is is key so a dermatologist faced
with a patient who has a skin lesion
will make some assessment about
the likelihood of a lesion being
melanoma
so unfortunately today dermatologists
can make errors
some melanomas are being missed and
some skin lesions which are perfectly
benign are being excised
needlessly so what we can do here
is essentially ask the computer to make
a deep analysis over an image
so this image is then being sent to the
computer
and it's being automatically analyzed
and what the computer is telling us
about this image is that there's a very
high probability that it corresponds to
melanoma
what we're finding in our own internal
retrospective research
is that the computer can be as accurate
as 95
so this compares to the best clinical
experts today
that are between 75 and 84 in
recognizing melanoma
it is not a tool that would replace uh
the clinical expert rather it provides
them
with additional analysis over the skin
lesion images
by providing reaches into large
databases
of similar lesions
[Music]
this is a vision of a future where
humans and machines work hand in hand
complementing one another's skills i
look forward to a time when
you know every professional in fact you
know two three billion professionals
around the world
are all able to have their own personal
cognitive assistant
that can help them do their daily jobs
and that changes
the nature of expertise humanity will
move to a completely different place
in terms of expertise and how we apply
our knowledge and our
experience into real world problems and
therefore make the world a better place
just like we've had machines that could
augment people's muscles in the in the
prior industrial revolutions
uh or up can help people you know search
vast amounts of
information like in the in the internet
era i
look at the next revolution as
machines augmenting people's cognitive
capabilities
that's how i think about it
martin ford remains cautious believing
artificial intelligence is going to
fundamentally change the way we live
and work and challenge us like never
before
we're not prepared for the disruption is
coming
we're going to see things get worse
before they get better
in particular the impact on the job
market and the impact on
the incomes and the livelihoods for
average people
so you know in the short term things
could be pretty difficult
but in the longer term if we do adapt to
this then
i think there are reasons to be really
optimistic i mean you can imagine
an almost utopian kind of future where
no one has to do
a job that's dangerous or that they
really hate or that's really boring
where
technology takes on more and more of
that and
if we can get to that point of course
then that's a tremendously positive
outcome
so i think that all of that is really
possible and it could be
one of the best things that's ever
happened to humanity but it will require
that we adapt to it
and that's going to be a staggering
[Music]
challenge
[Music]
so
you